so which of your friends and family
freaked out the most when you told them
that you got cast in a steven spielberg
movie called west side story
i think
i think my mom just freaked out because
my mom is a big theater fan um
um she did theater in in back in cuba
when she lived there and she was just
this was like a dream come true that you
know i was able to almost do what she
wanted to do so she was so excited about
it and so
it was just unbelievable yeah yeah my
mom
my mom was a little like you did what
oh my god
yeah it was a very funny moment she's
and my mother is a woman of few words
so
it was uh it was pretty great
uh like both of you and the planet i am
a huge steven spielberg fan and i am
curious you know did you have any
expectations going in of what it would
be like to work with him and did those
expectations get sort of achieved or
what surprised you about working with
him
well i i don't know about you but i
watched the the spielberg documentary i
believe it was on amazon prime at the
time and i
thought i was going to walk in
uh to an experience with the director
who was going to tell me exactly what he
wanted and how he wanted it and so i
just assumed i was like great i'm going
to be ready for him to
be very very clear and i'm going to
deliver
and then
i got there and it was the complete
opposite
he was sort of like
no i hired you because i trust you amita
is yours and run wild
and there was not a moment that he
wasn't asked he wasn't paying attention
or asking me he was like did that feel
good for you did that feel authentic
some does that feel off
do we want to try something different he
was constantly curious and constantly
asking me questions wanted to make sure
that that it was in line with
not only my understanding of the
character but my understanding of my
lived experience um because he was very
interested in allowing our lived
experiences to inform these characters
and it was just incredibly collaborative
so
uh my expectation was totally shattered
because i got an even better version of
spielberg than i
anticipated
no i feel exactly the same way i went in
thinking that i was just gonna be this
puppet and i was ready to you know just
oh you want me to stand there i'll stand
there you want me to oh here my hand
here okay you know i was i was expecting
that and then i go in and like you said
he's just like
just you do you do whatever you want to
do
and it's scary because it's a huge
response
responsibility he's giving all this
trust over to you
and i you know i'm just kind of blown
away that he trusts me that much um
and yeah so it completely shattered my
expectations and in the end i think it
benefits us as artists because he forces
you to believe in yourself he forces you
to be strong and to be confident and to
go out there and show
what you can do you know he's not there
to tell you what to do he's there to
push you to do what you want to do so
that was incredible yeah
i don't think enough people realize what
it really takes to make a movie on this
scale and scope the behind the scenes
the pre-production the production the
post-production the list goes on and on
and the musical numbers forget it so
what do you wish more people knew
about making like a musical on this size
you know
i think you you literally hit the nail
on the head
the general public doesn't realize how
how hard it is to get not only get a
movie like this made but there are
countless people involved in this
process like hundreds of jobs
are given to people so that we can make
this movie and it's it's not just the
work of one man it's the work of
many many many people hundreds of
incredible and so much you know
blood sweat tears effort
yeah
emphasis on tears goes into making this
movie a reality um
i don't think people realize that in
general about movie making but
specifically epic films like this one
um
you know
it's a work of art it's it's very
carefully crafted um
and there's so much attention to every
little detail in this um and nothing
nothing is there for no reason
everything is there for a very specific
reason um and that's just how stephen
works yeah um and yeah just a commitment
to detail especially when you take on a
cultural project like this
um and i have to say our team was very
sensitive to
our culture and they brought in experts
and they went to groups of people who
potentially did not agree with them and
actively wanted to know what their
grievances were so that they could try
and correct them and that is something
we don't see in the entertainment
industry happen every day and i think
it's an example of how we can and should
be moving forward
i completely agree i really want to
commend both of you on your performances
you guys did such great work thank you
so much for your time so much thank you
so much thank you